uh it's it's continued bad news after
bad news for donald trump over the last
few days
a court ruled on wednesday that donald
trump can no longer block his tax
returns
from a subpoena in a grand jury in new
york and will have to turn them over
this is part of the investigation into
donald trump's business practices and
it's all falling apart for him this was
a 3-0 decision
in the second u.s circuit court of
appeals the decision is
trump must turn over his tax returns
great right so now the prosecution gets
the tax returns right
no not yet donald trump's lawyer jay
sekulow you might remember him from the
impeachment hearings
says that they will now appeal to the
supreme court
an agreement was reached where this
decision from the lower court
won't be enforced for almost a couple of
weeks
so that donald trump can appeal to the
supreme court
so bottom line these prosecutors
are not going to have trump's taxes
before the election
even if these prosecutors get donald
trump's taxes that doesn't mean that
we get them from them but something has
changed
we've already learned a ton about what
is in donald trump's taxes from that
bombshell new york times report from
i think it was about 10 days ago
although at this point it feels like six
months ago
where we learned that donald trump paid
no federal tax in ten of the last 15
years
we learned that donald trump paid only
750
in federal taxes in 2016 and only
another 750
in 2017 we learned that donald trump has
more than
420 million dollars in debt so the real
reason that this decision matters
is that trump is clearly becoming
unglued
and this won't help whether trump has
been experiencing
steroid-induced mania for the last few
days from the dexamethasone prescription
for his covid
or it's the polls that are triggering
him or whatever
he has been unhinged even by his
standards
and we may see i don't know what the
next week will bring i don't know what
this weekend will bring
by by by tuesday when we're back from
the holiday
donald trump may have already descended
into a full-blown
public narcissistic rage i was actually
thinking the other day
imagine if donald trump realized he
could go live on twitter
via video and imagine he just did it and
went live
and went completely crazy it would truly
be something else and what has been
sort of like a simmer for a few days is
quickly becoming a rolling boil and it
could be that way by election day if
things keep going going this way the
supreme court appointment now
appears as though it could be delayed
don jr reportedly thinks donald trump
needs an intervention
i don't yet believe that we've reached
the low point the sort of
full bottom or the full uh climax really
of donald trump's rage yet
and as far as the taxes go the new york
times
themselves might have more documents and
may actually drop a bombshell in the
next couple of weeks
they may find a way remember that the
new york times decided they weren't
going to publish the actual tax
documents because
they believed that the copies they have
probably because of some markings or
stamps or whatnot that are on them
would expose who their source is on
trump's tax documents it's conceivable
that the source will say out me or
that the new york times will find a way
to release the documents without outing
the source and so we may even see the
actual tax documents before this is all
said and done
after this decision was made by the
court donald trump quickly went nuclear
within minutes of the decision he went
to twitter
to deliver another all-capital letters
rant where he said
wow now do something about this
the biggest of all political scandals in
history
biden obama and crooked hillary
led this treasonous plot biden shouldn't
be allowed to run
got caught now in all seriousness
as far as the appeal to the supreme
court on this decision
should the supreme court even hear this
case of course
it's the president and of course donald
trump has every right
to appeal each decision against him on
different grounds if that's what he
wants to do
but at some point does it become
frivolous different legal experts
have different perspectives on that but
i suppose
at some point we will see so the plan
for today and for next week we are going
to hear from some of you
we are going to talk later on in the
program about
whether trump's coronavirus helps or
hurts him
how long i believe it will take the
final results of the 2020 election to be
given
to us we will talk about the recent
trends with older voters moving towards
joe biden and away from donald trump
monday we are off call it columbus day
call it indigenous people's day
we tend to take federal holidays off the
staff really needs it so we will be off
on monday
and then back tuesday through election
day and it is going to be
uh a wild wild few weeks so i'm glad
that you are
with me here make sure you're following
me on twitter at d pacman
membership always is the best way to
support our work and the show
you can grab a membership at
joinpacman.com and you have only about
three and a half weeks left
to use the coupon code 2020 now we
started the coupon code 2020 now
when i determined i used my uh judgment
to determine it is now the election the
election has started
that code will work until november 3rd
and then it is
bye-bye 2020 now saves you 66 percent
off of the membership of your choice
grab one at
and we'll be back right after this every
single day
the trump administration shows us what
happens when anti-science christian
conservatives have power in government
on everything from climate change to
fighting this pandemic
we cannot afford another four years of
donald trump one of our sponsors today
is the free thought equality super pac
both they and i want to remind you that
voting against donald trump
in the presidential election is one of
the most important things you can do
right now
if you want religious conservatives to
have less power
and you want science to have more
influence in government make sure you're
registered to vote
make the commitment to vote on or before
november 3rd
i also encourage you to check out the
center for free thought equality
which is an advocacy group that promotes
evidence-based public policy
and support secular candidates running
for office becoming a member is
completely free
gives you access to tons of excellent
resources related
to secularism in politics just visit
cfequality.org
you can find the link right underneath
this video this message was paid for by
the free thought equality super pac
and is not authorized by any candidate
or candidates committee